I'm going to pull this one straight
another program I think if you get how
this works the rest the exercises
following much the same okay so here's
the stock standard one alright and I'm
gonna give you a you get to assume some
stuff in this usually the characteristic
over induction proofs is you assume
nothing even basic things you don't
assume and you have to prove them by
induction right but there's an important
step here that you need what you have to
share okay so assuming the product rule
we're going to prove the rule for
differentiating powers okay in other
words when you differentiate X to the N
you should get how good a weird calculus
come on year 12 when you differentiate X
then you get an X to the N minus 1 okay
so how do we do it well oh by the way
you try and stop me when you try and
work out why why you have to assume in
front of you
okay unfortunately when you get this
question in the exams often they'll
leave that part out they're just trying
to rely on you remembering that this
sort of no other way to do this or there
is a way it just turns it into an
induction question that turns it into a
calculus question okay so what do we do
first step test
now what's the first allowable value
I think well let's think about it okay
if you take some cases okay if X sorry
an or you could have what what would
this be this would be X and they miss
return it to Y correct it'll be one the
power of X the power of 0 sorry 1 times
x2 perhaps you would sure enough this
one okay can we go any better than that
well exit power 0 is 1 and when you
differentiate that you get 0 times X to
the power zero serving zero right Oh
what okay so it actually works for 0 and
for 1 so see what's the lesson values
let's test and equals zero okay
now remember how I said assume nothing
except what they telling you to us you
right
so here when I do my right hand side
that monkey hot because I'm just
substituting things in right so I say
yeah this is going to be 0 X 2 0 minus 1
which is 0 on X which is 0 okay now when
you got the left hand side I've got the
derivative of X to the 0 which is the
derivative of 1 now most people would
say well clearly that's 0 and so
therefore I've done I've heard opposed
okay but I'm gonna be finicky right and
I want to give you guys more detail
rather less so remember if we're not
assuming that by definition you know
it's a horizontal line has to be 0 the
derivative how would you show that the
derivative of something is anything in
this case hawlucha is equal to 0 well
what do you go back to what your most
fundamental way of showing the druze
first principles right now you're like
the first principle stuff the good thing
is first principles is very easy when
you've got the function as simplest
okay so even though it's kind of gross
just deal with that and see what happens
okay so do you remember what first
principles is how to start it start to
limit good as H approaches zero of what
you get yeah okay now let me just stop
let me just write over on the right hand
side the left hand side so I remember
what this thing is
okay so this is what should be what
we're taking the limit off and you
remember it comes from rise over run
remember that this is ringing bells from
a year ago
all right now what's f of X plus h when
f of X is 1 f of whatever right means
you sub in whatever to wherever you X is
well right now we're at X is yeah yeah
well they're actually there the exit
plus h to the power of 0 right so it's
just 1 f of X plus h is just 1 right and
f of X is also 1 that's weird isn't it
but it's true it looks like it should be
a smiley face but it's not okay so
that's that's first principle yeah I
told you it wasn't that hard right so
that's gonna be the limit as H
approaches 0 of 0 on H which is U now it
equals the right hand side so I'll show
okay now is you know what you prove it
this is what we actually do want to
prove the derivative when you raise the
power up by once that's funny
we'll give you a k plus one out the
front and the minus one in the plus one
elimination so I just have a camera all
right so where are you gonna go well you
can stop would you go the right hand
side the left hand side I think we
should go to the left hand side I'm
reason being our minds and derivatives
are that kind of thing do better because
if you make the other way you'd have to
integrate in the ear okay so let's get
from the left hand side and go towards
the right okay so the left hand side is
equal to the derivative of X to the k
plus 1 what is that what can we do with
it well we can't do anything with this
rule because we that's what we're trying
to prove right so instead I'm going to
give it as R get it this is why we've
had to assume it right I'm gonna
consider it as a product what kind of
product is this yeah so that plus 1
right
it means it's X to the K times X that's
just all mean it's just multiplied by
another Mattox right so I'm gonna write
it like this by the way you might have
seen before how much your frustration
sometimes some bat species at the dots
to indicate multiplication you're like
why don't we have two ways of writing
writing multiplication well the answer
is number one actually they mean two
different things there's the dot
products
if you are if you're unfortunate enough
to go and do vector calculus at
university you'll learn what the
difference between these two for our
purposes
they actually do function the same but a
useful to us anyway
so that my lion doesn't look like that
because that's just confusing right okay
so I'm gonna use dots for the rest of
this proof just so I don't confuse them
with my answers that is a killer
unfortunately so here's the thing that's
where the decimal place should always be
except because in any life you know
every program the types it's actually
very hard to get the dot in the middle
the dot defaults down the bottom so
everyone writes 3.5 as this which is
actually three times five but you know
it's it's a two-lane Microsoft Word
that's just I blame I plain bill good
okay so let's get going now you see why
nice you know why I had to assume this
okay by the way you actually can prove
the PACU go back to your eleven would
look that hard but if we were to prove
it like if this induction proof was set
for marks okay play with the box carrier
and you know it has to be improving that
thing so I'm not really testing
induction I'm testing calculus okay
that's why they give it to you okay and
even if they don't say that you still
would have to do it for this all right
so what is the product rule you may
remember then if you've got two
functions U times V right then the
derivative is remember it's it's right
so let's be careful and let's get all of
these terms down here okay now there's
my so we start with just be first which
is X okay and then you - you - years
now usually you wouldn't just be able to
say it's equal to one right
we will probably actually have to have
proved it that testing is right I'm
gonna stick in here just because I don't
wanna make this Super Bowl but you could
have actually tested for N equals one
and then you'd be able to say that's why
the derivative X is well so there's my
being a my you - yeah I'll add you and
before rather than writing V - straight
away I'm gonna make the assumption a
little obvious by just saying will be -
- is our way of saying different kid
right so I'm a differentiate X to the K
you can see I'm writing it like this to
make the link clearer with my suction
okay all right so I've got one buttocks
okay plus X lots of this and there's my
assumption
okay now I think at this point most of
the twists and turns are done okay the
fact that you needed the product rule
the fact that you had to do first
principles rather than just say it's
zero or one whichever take case you test
here you can see it factorizes quite
nicely back yep okay but just to finish
that off three
okay
now that wasn't too traumatic right
apart from these two weird things in
there particularly people don't see that
they have to use the product rule here
because it looks less as simple as it is
right have you noticed that's one of the
things we're going to have in with
induction that things may look simple
you've got to make a little more
complicated first before you can
actually work the induction magic on it